well I think there also should be a
concerted effort to try to stop this
divide I think there should be an effort
to try to do this I agree when you look
at the corporate media's coverage it is
amping it up it is saying you need it
they're going to attack us these people
are going to come into your bedroom when
you're sleeping and you see this kind of
this kind of bombastic language from the
corporate media and in Independent Media
has been saying hey hey let's let's try
to stop this madness people are just
screaming there's a lot of insane people
that are getting on on on you know the
microphones getting on the major
communication highways but sadly big
Tech social media also elevates those
voices big Tech social media that of
course has connections to of course the
intelligence agencies that of course the
works on the beheads of the federal
government censors voices and and UPS
voices that of course uh they want to
promote and let's be honest from from
the last few years they have been
promoting drama they have been promoting
infighting they have been promoting the
most toxic voices that get the most
amount of attention that gets the most
amount of clicks